parents agreed in when they got divorced
to pay for their kids college tuition um
so at the start of each semester my
husband's mom would send him cash and
his dad would ask that he' take out a
loan in my husband's name that his dad
um verbally agreed to pay back at the
end of um College basically so um my
husband also worked full-time 40 hours
he ended up getting all of his tuition
reimbursed that at the end of each
semester he would send his mom the cash
back and his dad the other half and he
thought he was paying those loans off
but come to find out he spent that money
instead and now my husband still has
$177,000 in student loans in his name
that that fall on us or your
husb yeah ex and so do we delay buying
the house to pay that off yes okay I'm
sorry I'm guessing he doesn't have
$17,000 to honor his word and pay this
off right uh he lives paycheck to
paycheck and probably will for the rest
of his life